multiplied expressing the product in
scientific notation so let's multiply
first and then let's try to get what we
have in scientific notation actually
before we do that lets just reven
remember what it means to be in
scientific notation so it'll be in
scientific notation and actually each of
these numbers right here are in
scientific notation
it's going to be the form a times 10 to
some power where a can be greater than
or equal to 1 and it is going to be less
than 10 so both of these numbers are
greater than or equal to 1 and they are
less than 10 and they're being
multiplied by some power of 10 so let's
see how we can multiply this so this
over here this is just the exact same
thing so if I do this in magenta this is
the exact same thing as 9 point 1 times
10 to the sixth times times 3 point 2
times I actually don't have to write an
8
I could write let me write it all with
the dot notation to make it a little bit
more straightforward so this is equal to
9 point doing that magenta is equal to 9
point 1 times 10 to the sixth times
times let me do it in this green color
times 3 point 2 times 10 to the negative
fifth power now in multiplication and
you know this comes from the associative
property essentially allows us to remove
these parentheses it says look you can
multiply like that first or you can
actually multiply these guys first you
can reassociate them and the commutative
property tells us that we can rearrange
this thing right here and what I want to
rearrange is I want to multiply the 9
point one times the 3 point 2 first and
then multiply that times 10 to the 6
times 10 to the negative 5 so I'm just
going to rearrange this using the
commutative property so this is the same
thing as nine point one times three
point two times three point two and I'm
going to reassociate so I'm going to do
these first and then that times that
times 10 to the sixth 10 to the six
times 10 to the negative five times 10
to the negative five and the reason why
this is useful is that this is really
easy to multiply we have the same base
here base to end so we can and we're
taking the product so we can add the
exponents so this part right over here
this part right over here 10 to the 6
times 10 to the negative 5 that's going
to be 10 to the 6 minus 5 power or
essentially just 10 to the first power
which is really just equal to 10 and
that's going to be multiplied by nine
point one times three point two so let
me do that over here so if I have nine
point one times three point two so first
I'm going to ignore the decimal so I'm
just going to treat it like 91 times 32
so if 2 times 1 is 2 2 times 9 is 18
take a 0 here because I'm in the tenths
place now I'm multiplying everything
really by 30 not just by 3 that's why my
zero is there and I multiply 3 times 1
to get 3 and then 3 times 9 is 27 and so
it is 2 2 plus 0 so I'm adding here 2
Plus 0 is 2 8 plus 3 is 11 carry or
regroup that one 1 plus 1 is 2 2 plus 7
is 9 and then I have a 2 here so 91
times 32 is 2912
but I didn't multiply 91 times 32 I
multiply nine point one times three
point two so what I want to do is count
the number of digits I have behind the
decimal point I have one two digits
behind the decimal point and so I'll
have to have two digits behind the
decimal point in the answer so one two
I'll stick the decimal right over there
so this part right over here comes out
to be twenty nine point one two so you
might say you might feel like we're done
this kind of looks like scientific
notation I have a number times a power
of 10 but remember remember this number
has to be greater than or equal to one
which it is and less than 10 but this
number is not less than 10 it's not in
scientific notation so we can do is
let's just write this number in
scientific notation and then we could
use the power of 10 part to multiply
that with this power of 10 so 29.2 or
sorry 29 point one two this is the same
thing as two point nine one two notice
what did i do to go from there to there
just move the decimal to the left or
another way to think about it if I
wanted to go from here to there if I
want to go from here to there what can I
do to this what I would multiply it by
10 if I multiply it by 10 I would move
the decimal to the right it would go
from 2.9 to 29 so if I want to write
this value this is just this times 10
all right so - 29 point 1 2 is the same
thing as 2 point 9 1 2 times 10 and now
this is in scientific notation but
that's just this part and I still have
to multiply it by another 10 so times
another 10 and so to finish up this
problem we get to point to point nine
1/2 times 10 times 10 or 10 to the first
times 10 to the first well what's that
well that's going to be this part right
over here that's just 10 squared so it's
2.9 1/2 times 10 to the second power and
we are done